[Musik]
[Applaus]
bauen sie die achte
beste man will
spüren ist
[Musik]
der weg zur besten armee der welt führt
uli maurer heute zu den sondereinheiten
der schweizer armee
truppenbesuche marco riemer für den gang
ins feld ist er deshalb stets gerüst
an diesem tag zeigen die elitesoldaten
ihrem obersten chef wie sie bei einem
überfall auf einen botschafter reagieren
würden
schnell effizient und professionell
[Musik]
uli maurer wäre kein guter verkäufer
seine armee wenn er zu dieser vorführung
nicht auch einige journalisten
eingeladen hätte
und so schaut interessiert zu und lässt
sich dabei zuschauen
was die jugend das ich halte absolut
in einer perfektion an wieder eine sehr
große engagement das überzeugt mich
etwas mehr möglich hervorragender
soldaten
ja da haben wir wirklich mit jeder
anderen
spezialseite was mir doch
ein lob das oberste missionieren der
mitte durchaus freut auch länger als
kommandant der sondereinheiten nicht nur
die fähigkeiten sondern leute kennt
sondern auch ihre grenzen
sie vergleichen weil die amerikaner die
ungefähr 50.000 special forces soldaten
haben also das ist klar dass wir nicht
in die gleiche die gleiche league
spielen oder aber trotzdem sind sie teil
der besten armee der welt
haben sie das ist der auffassung der
herr bundesrat auf der politische leveln
und
er hat dieser fassung ich bei soldaten
ich erkenne dass wir einige stärken
haben und einige schwächen haben als
soldaten kann ich mir das erlauben zu
sagen
es spricht für die armee dass die leute
mit bodenhaftung in ihren reihen
beschäftigt
es reicht wenn der oberste chef eine
vision formuliert die ein- und op grenzt
doch wo die mauer ist nicht abgeholt
ganz pragmatisch und aus spargründen
legte er verschiedene sondereinheiten
hier an der canary zusammen
doch davon will ich
geb dir zusammen führen verschiedene
kulturen zusammenbringen was ich glaube
gut und war und das ist
das wichtig für
das man akzeptieren so lautet das motto
in der kürze liegt die synergien der
trainer-manager
ja doch wer muss sparen
eine gebaut wie massa und die stadt das
raummodul gut oder als befürchtet
und so macht sich armee manager maurer
wieder auf amanda knox noch mehr
sparpotenzial zu ordnen
[Musik]
sparen lässt sich beispielsweise unter
dem boden bei den naturschutz
unterständen die im militärjargon
7800 solche und ähnliche meist kleinere
bunker hat die schweizer armee in den
70er und 80er jahren in der ganzen
schweiz in feld und wald ver betoniert
unser
land
also haben wir
nicht sagt sie und wenn ich das sofort
auch ein drittel nicht beraten ein
drittel hocker untertitel bett schlafe
drin
sein verstand ich das mit mir bin dass
ich jetzt immer man tisch
ist ein ende es war mehr drin weil
uhr lima sparen muss räumt die
logistikbasis der armee derzeit den
größten teil dieser atom schutz
unterstände aus
[Musik]
hunderte von millionen franken hatte die
armee in solche bunker investiert in
beton metall rosten und wassertanks aus
heutiger sicht umsonst aber immerhin nun
lässt sie sparen
sind sagte 20 stunden und bekommt wo man
immer nur ausmachen
26 stunden weniger filter testen
richtungen prüfen und schimmelpilz
bekämpft
26.000 weniger arbeit eine ersparnis von
etwa 2000 franken pro asyl oder 10
millionen franken pro jahr für alle rück
gebauten unterstellt
10 millionen das ist nicht allzu viel
aber manchmal zählt hier auch der will
ausgeben will die armee das geld nicht
zuletzt für neuer kampfjets vom typ
geräten
anfang mai können schweizer piloten in
schweden zum ersten mal ein
vorläufermodell des kampfjets testen
denn der bundesrat für gut drei
milliarden kaufen möchte die stimmung am
hauptsitz der firma sab in den shopping
ist leicht angespannt das vbs erlaubt
das filmen nicht aber interviews mit dem
piloten vor dem start
seine konzentration solle ganz dem flug
gelten den test abläufen der mission wie
pilot fabio antonini selber sagt
fabio antonini hat in seiner karriere
schon tausende von flugstunden gesammelt
doch jede testflug ist eine
herausforderung
normal nicht
nervös ist man einfach konzentriert kann
mir vorstellen wie skifahrer vor
dem beginn von meiner ränder der muss
einfach sein ihre länder konzentrieren
und das ist und den kapitän gelassen
sein und tatsächlich
alle getestet oder
die experten nennen diesen jet den grip
in demonstrator es ist kein neues
flugzeug sondern ein umgebauter kampfjet
vom typ krippen de die frage für die
schweiz ist erreicht der aufgepeppte
alter crippen beim testflug die
versprochene leistung
wenige stunden zuvor die test crew auf
dem weg zum briefing auch hier sind
keine interviews erlaubt zum team
gehören nebst pilot fabio antonini auch
flugingenieure aus der schweiz sowie
testpiloten von saab
eine stunde soll der flug dauern über
100 exakt definierte flugmanöver muss
fabio antonini absolvieren
mit am tisch auch jörg weber der den
kampfjet kauf auf schweizer seite leitet
der krieg vor einem jahr hat in der
bundesrat ausgewählt ein wesentlicher
grund der krippen ist deutlich günstiger
als die konkurrenz und dank nachrüstung
soll auch die flugleistung vergleichbar
seien da gerät man eher für das neue
tragbare bevor das wird im nasa gebaut
wird der nächste monat als nächstes für
die gebaut zum technik am flugzeug den
achsen wie das neue triebwerk
dahinter das ist seebeck forum vom
einfach zur stammt sich als bewerber
habe es bringt mehr schub und damit
besser die leistungen für das flugzeug
in der neuen version
das triebwerk der größere trank steht im
zentrum der tests di fabio antonini
durchführen soll in wenigen minuten ist
er über dem testgebiet
im kontrollzentrum wir bewachen die
testingenieure und jörg weber jede
bewegung des flugzeugs jörg weber wagt
eine erste analyse
mit
neue triebwerk testet unter dx11
erster pkw hotel positiv
nach einer stunde kehrt fabio antonini
wie geplant vom test zurück
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der flug war kein reines ausloten der
maximalen flugleistung fabio antonini
musste testen ob der krippen einen
typischen schweizer luft überwachungs
auftrag ausführen kann
das haben wir das jetzt können auch er
prüfe natürlich nur ein schritt wo jetzt
angetan die sind die allgemeine leistung
vom von systemen natürlich muss man in
der lage die veteranen und alle die an
das system den würden den gesprächen
funktionieren
absolut
kein wunder strahlt projektleiter jörg
weber es gab offenbar keine probleme
alles scheint auf kurs das vbs werte die
testflüge als erfolg und wird wenige
tage später dennoch von einem medien
gewitter überrascht
der sonntagspresse kommt der krippen
unter beschuss
es gibt lecks in bundesbern
der krippen ist wie ein messer
das schlecht schneidet zitiert die
sonntagszeitung
flugingenieur sera aus dem vertraulichen
protokoll einer parlamentarischen
kommission
und weiter man werde bei der lieferung
die versprochene operationelle effizienz
nicht haben
vor den 98 neuen komponenten seien beim
testflug 07 schon eingebaut gewesen
wurde kolportiert ein kleiner ja zu
kleiner teil suggeriert die zeitung
uli maurer sagt die lecks seien eine
verdammte sauerei
nach den indiskretionen erhält der
krippen eine neue gegner von rechts fdp
präsident philippe müller dieser meint
nun hier müsste ein ausstieg überlegt
werden
der kauf des krippen ist umstritten auch
weil die armee dafür anderen ort sparen
muss
trotzdem gibt aber swiss im frühling
bekannt dass man für einen möglichen
kauf im jahre 2015 drohnen evaluieren im
rennen die heron 1 und die hermes 900
preis
300 bis 400 millionen franken
beide anbieter stammen aus israel
das stößt auf kritik
strategieexperte albert daher nennt die
wahl sehr unglücklich und
nationalrat geri müller sorgt das
geschäft sei unappetitlich
doch damit nicht genug ärger gibt es im
frühling auch wegen sturmgewehren in
27.000 fällen weist das vbs nicht mit
letzter sicherheit ob soldaten das
gewehr zurückgegeben hatten oder nicht
ein armeesprecher sagte die armee hat
27.000 datensätze zur rücknahme der
persönlichen ausrüstung verloren
armeechef andré blattmann erklärt tags
darauf an einer pressekonferenz wir
wollen ordnung schaffen und
er nennt einen chef armeewaffen
[Musik]
es ist der zweite juli 2012 am abend
zuvor wurde spanien fussball
europameister in der ganzen schweiz
rücken knapp 8000 junge männer in die
rekrutenschule
allein in chur sind es 650
es scheint als ob alles so sei wie vor
20 30 jahren
[Musik]
spanische frauen stolz sie halte nichts
von dem schweizer militär
[Musik]
unterschreitet
dieselben abläufe
die gleichen sprüche der soweit ernen
vorgesetzten
[Musik]
es werde sofort werden kürzer die
scheißegal macht sie einfach nicht
brechen
die nächsten 21 wochen werden die
rekruten zu infanteristen ausgebildet
650 individuen werden nun im sinne der
armee normiert
[Musik]
die namensliste gleicht jener der
fußball-nationalmannschaft dort wie hier
stehen auffallend viele männer mit
fremdländischen namen für die schweiz
ein
und was erwarten die rekruten
zum kind zum mann
wichtiger
sein
fachkollege einfach irgendwelche der
freundschaft aufbauen und
businesskunden space machen
[Musik]
verletzt sich ein zwischenmenschliches
militär und zusammenhalt was meinen sie
wie zwischen möglich weil es kann man
also vor ort werden die beamtin der
personen über 60 aus ständig mit respekt
behandeln und dass ich gut verhalten das
man halt einmal vor und schießt doch
genau da und es macht spaß es
macht spaß ja das ist dass ich alles
sehr leid und was man muss als folge
[Musik]
ich konnte mir
dass
ich gestraft
werk das jetzt besser aus das ist gutes
auto musste daraus
ziehen dass man sie so viel geschehen
[Musik]
sie ein ihre grund erzigkeit sie
grundsätzlich vor der haie mit knop und
völlig pro mente oder anderen eventuelle
korrekturen aber
das ist kein problem und werden zu
dementsprechend sehen es ist
nur selbstverständlich hat das jeder
interessierte kann ihn als einer minute
ein cd eine zwölf wochen dauert stehen
den hätte bis gleich denn heinz
geleistet
das zurück rosskur wurde aus
kostengründen aufgehoben die rekruten
werden in st gallen von zivilisten zu
rekruten
[Musik]
kopf hoch
nun ruft
die angehenden armeeangehörigen sind mit
gelassenheit gar mit einer gewissen lust
bei der sache
[Musik]
wir haben verträge der kasache
komisch fühlt also mit der zivilist
weiter ganz ehrlich sein
kann der arzt eine offizielle sie sind
wahnsinnig motiviert ist es nur schon
oder entwickelt so für heute mit ich bin
schon sieht 16 15 uhr ich will vom
militär mir die heime und kollegah
closer und
ich bin jetzt jetzt bin ich halt im
militär und ja nichts kostet und bevor
bereitet motiviert freue mich auf die
zeit auf die 120 woche
[Musik]
dass die heutigen guten
überdurchschnittlich motiviert sind
stellt auch das militär kader fest
wirklich immer stand anzeige des witwers
meinungsbildung leisten
dass es gewisse sachen gibt wir
materiellen bereich und dann ist alles
optimal ist normal dass gibt
2009 ist auch da wo in entwicklung sind
neue schuhe rucksäcke mal aber das
material wird recruiter fassen ist
sicher das material
[Musik]
am 2 reichstag ist die transformation
zumindest optisch abgeschlossen
jetzt sind sie offiziell mitglied
wissen sie wie soll das
anzuschauen oder social media ja ja es
soll ja gesagt gut ich begrüße diese
gute gedankengutes ziel dass man das
wort erreicht man dass am schluss ist
will ja das mit amerikaner holt als
schweiz ist schwierig aber
ich finde grundsatz dass ich nach dem
leben
ende juni das nächste offizielle kapitel
in der kampfjet beschaffung
wird die schwedische
verteidigungsministerin karin enström
nach norwegen ein
das vbs sagt dem schwedischen gast die
flugkünste der schweizer luftwaffe ob
das nötig ist bleibe dahingestellt
denn eigentlich geht es nur darum dass
die schweiz und schweden eine
absichtserklärung unterzeichnen
inhaltlich gibt es wenig her aber man
merkt die beiden verstehen sich
uli maurer nutzt die gelegenheit und
betont dass er und die armeespitze
unbeirrbar sein
wir wollen den klippen daran gibt es
keinen zweifel und brown lässt sich
nicht drücken und so konkretisieren die
schweizer streben den plan den neuen
gruppen zusammen zu kaufen
[Musik]
der erste der offizielle teil des
programms ist damit erledigt
schwedische flagge auf dem männlichen
vor einer mönch und jungfrau
dazu etwas schweizer heimat romantik
[Musik]
wie sich später zeigen wird hilft diese
charmeoffensive bei den verhandlungen
über einen staatsvertrag in dem die
schweiz und schweden den jet kauf regeln
und indem sie schweden bereit erklärt
die entwicklungskosten für das neue
flugzeug voll zu übernehmen
uli maurer ist nicht der geborene
diplomat aber mit berg ambiente gäste
entzücken das liegt ihm und so
unterzeichnete karen entströmen an
diesem tag nur eine absichtserklärung
und ein alkohol im spätsommer allerdings
unterschreibt schweden einen vertrag der
vor allem für die schweiz vorteile zu
erteilen scheint
dabei ist in der schweiz der kauf des
krippen noch alles andere als sicher
versuche geschehen war noch groß pro
verschiedene sieht etwas nur versuch
hat's krippe entweder ganz kippen oder
ein anderes flugzeug überhaupt und muss
immer wieder betonen dass das weggeben
sagt ein bundesrat der nach eigenen
angaben überhaupt nicht gerne fliegt und
der sich zum wohle des vaterlandes doch
immer wieder in den helikopter setzt
[Musik]
hier öffnet sich das tor für
schützenpanzer vom typ m 113 es sind
jene panzer von denen urlauber vor zwei
jahren sagte man habe sie hier gefunden
hohn und spott waren uli maurer damals
gewiss nicht nur dass uli maurer
befürchtete die entsorgung dieser panzer
würde millionen kosten
zwei jahre nach dem sport werden die
panzer nun tatsächlich entsorgt tranzer
notabene deren standort die dafür
zuständigen beim vbs jederzeit könnten
mitarbeiter der logistikbasis bauen hier
im wallis kleinteile nichtmetallische
ausrüstung und wieder verwendbares
material aus
[Musik]
zuständig für den entsorgungs prozess
ist der von google hier links im bild
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ist eine aluminiumkonstruktion
moment war ich verschiedene schritte
versucht das system der veränderten der
beruhigen arts ba eigene sitz ist der
zusatzschutz hier montiert wurde in den
80er jahren als damals die stammt von
der technik zwischen 40 pedro ich
verändere mich einfach nur abschießen
sondern hängt explosive artig apps aus
dem hinterhalt und donizetti
geschäftskonzept nummer als bewaffnet
verfügt das fahrzeug über eine 20 mm
kanone es ist eine kanone rosenkranz
flugzeug wo es bald worden ist und je
nach art einer monty worden ist weil
diese schützenpanzer aus sicht der armee
nutzlos geworden sind werden sie nun
entsorgt kritiker der entsorgung
monieren besser ein alter panzer als gar
kein gang sei
die panthers mit briefen baby wurde
lagere besser wird oder die länge dass
wir das material lagere umso höhere
werte um es wieder in betrieb und dazu
eine wand wird sich natürlich auch das
bedrohungspotenzial also das ist system
das herz in der st
georg a ist zwar technisch noch real
passt wurde
nur mit der neuen fassade lange das neue
city
und so schickt das vbs in diesem jahr
jeden monat 30 schützenpanzer wie ein
bauer seine kälbchen auf die reise zum
metzger
weil die panzer nun nicht mehr unnütz im
stollen herum stehen gewinnt die armee
lagerfläche zudem spart das vbs rund 150
tonnen unterhalb pro jahr umgerechnet
zwischen 10 und 20 tausend
mehr als 20 jahre nach dem ende des
kalten krieges entsorgt die schweizer
armee gerätschaften dies so und heute
kaum mehr braucht
[Musik]
beim fahrrad am bahnhof kampl treffen
wir männer die das ereignis
dokumentieren es sind mitglieder der
gruppe giardino
altgediente militärs die sich nach
eigenen angaben für eine starke
milizarmee einsetzen die gruppe giardino
hat sich in diesem jahr vehement gegen
die verschrottung der schützenpanzer
gewährt der waage sind einsatzfähig
[Musik]
wo man dahin in
bodman stand das sind mit der
armeespitze einmal gefragt was würde
damit einer vollmacht wann sieht braucht
würde vom november an irgendetwas großes
wird basieren und ein herz kreise sie
würde da eine
situationsanalyse machen und würde die
ihr wagen sofort wieder die äußeren
ampel wird material auf
milliarden muss sparen
na ja also es ist ja so habe
der
interne bundeswehr hinterher jahren der
thema 6 zu 1 und der bundesstaaten und
hinter der armee sicherheitspolitik ist
nicht auf der traktandenliste und das
ist problem
wie groß dieses problem ist darüber
gehen die meinungen in der politischen
landschaft auseinander
weitgehend unbestritten ist dass die
armee sparen muss wenn sie ein neues
flugzeug kaufen will und das ist nicht
einfach
[Musik]
die armee hat bereits viel abgebaut
gut 900 kampfpanzer hatte die armee vor
20 jahren nun sind es noch 134
[Musik]
abbau auch bei den kampfjets
271 waren es 1992
87 sind übrig geblieben
der bestand von 32.000 armee immobilien
wurde auf 26.000 einheiten reduziert
hier gebe es noch potenzial
zudem ist die armee von 800.000 man auf
gut 180 tausend mann geschrumpft
das verteidigungsbudget wurde dem vbs
von sechs milliarden auf rund vier
milliarden gekürzt
die schweizer armee
ist dramatisch geschrumpft
im internationalen vergleich belegt die
schweiz mit ihrem aktuellen budget
gerade einmal rang 131 mit ausgaben von
0,8 prozent des
bruttoinlandproduktes
die armee war schon immer eine eher
verschlossene gesellschaft und ihre
kasernen und munitionsdepots waren im
kalten krieg aber sehr ordentlich geheim
seit der kalte krieg vorbei ist und der
arme jahr für jahr das budget gekürzt
wird versucht sie die einst geheimen
anlagen zu versehen
das ist nicht immer einfach aber es gibt
firmen und privatpersonen die ein gut
1000 quadratmetern unterirdischer
lagerfläche plus umschwung interessiert
sind
interessant für
420.000 franken hat das vbs diese
kaverne ausgeschrieben ein kühler
ruhiger
geeignet beispielsweise als käse lager
oder für die pilzzucht
inbegriffen im preis der technikraum
wenn man einen notstopp also ich kenne
betrieb erwarten wir einen strom von
externen überrollten
die klassische unterhaltsaufwand die
studie wirtschaft darunter hautfarbene
zuvor 120 stunden arbeit fahren
natürlich auf null ab
[Musik]
anfang september knapp die hälfte der
rekrutenschule ist geschafft einen
beobachtungsposten in der nähe von chur
aus rekruten sind soldaten geworden
am frühen morgen taucht ein
überraschungsgast auf oberst im
generalstab peter baumgartner
die suche nach geeigneten kaderleuten
beschäftigt den schul kommandant
ihn musste der oberst nicht überzeugen
wenn details im privatleben koch eines
fünf sterne hauses ist bereits zum
scharfschützen befördert worden er will
mehr quote bis bewege ich
lud führer könne also dass das ein sehr
wichtiger punkt sie bereits seit das
bringt mir beruflich sicher was
natürlich eine ganze militärische drill
und stil auf wandern aber das ist sicher
auch ein erfahrung ist der junge jahre
machen war relativ beliebt oder großes
team könnte es leichter
soll dort heiß und
so also
qualifikation für den zugführer gehe ich
sehr gut aus mit dem er ohne den fehler
gespräche zur it ausbildung zum offizier
der störe nicht geschafft ein feuriger
appellation als wenn die kollegen von
soldaten sich am selben tag im
häuserkampf die übungsanlage
migrations gegner reihen habe in den
vergangenen monaten in der ganzen
ostschweiz aufsehen erregt
sie wollen die zunehmende einwanderung
der flüchtlinge aus ost land eindämmen
vor drei tagen drang eine gruppe von
fünf mitgliedern der gruppierung rein in
ein asylheim ein und habt drei aus
gelangten flüchtlinge aus ausland
entführt beifalls gabi horn tiere in der
übung müssen die soldaten haus für haus
durchsuchen
polizei
nicht ausgelöst werden was aber so
betreut von der heutigen armee nähmen
auch in kauf dass wirklich symmetrischen
armee auftritt sondern dass wir durch
muss auch subsidiären ist sie beruf und
spricht zur unterstützung der zivilen
behörden
und genau das ist was man muss
immer sie hier
links ganz links
rechts vom verein
muss rechts vom 03
[Musik]
ja es gibt viele spiele playstation 3
ein kranz halt
neues spiel im rathaus ist und da
private fonds zu führen hatte der 75
[Musik]
bru sda
schießen angreifend verhaften die jungen
soldaten mögen solche übungsszenarien es
ist eben doch nur ein spiel wie
brasilien und unsinn solcher übungen
gehen die meinungen allerdings
auseinander
es ist ein altes auf
30 7 milliarden gemacht aber das ist
jetzt vorbei
uli maurer hat an vielen fronten zu
kämpfen etwa in der asylpolitik auslöser
ist die arabische frühling das vbs zeigt
auf welche unterkünfte die armee im
falle einer flüchtlingswelle
vorübergehend verzichten könnte auf rund
6000 betten doch ein großteil davon ist
für asylbewerber nicht zu gebrauchen
weil die anlagen zu abgelegen sind oder
zivile auflagen nicht erfüllen
190 betten stehen anfang jahr
theoretisch zur verfügung
50 plätze auf dem jaunpass dazu 140
plätze in bättwil
doch in berlin leistet die bevölkerung
widerstand der bund kann den standort
deshalb auf absehbare zeit nicht nutzen
ein fiasko für alle beteiligten
uli maurer sieht das nicht so negativ
und sagt gegenüber 10 vor 10 es sei kein
so schlechtes signal nach außen dass man
hier um jedes bett kämpfen muss
die anderen bundesräte goutieren das
offenbar nicht und distanzieren sich
der gesamtbundesrat verpflichtet uli
maurer bis ende jahr 2000 betten für
asylbewerber zur verfügung zu stellen
eine hochgestellte vorgabe die das vbs
nicht erfüllen kann
auch wegen problemen mit zivilen
bauvorschriften eine zweite baustelle
das führungs informationssystem bisher
eine software mit der die armeeführung
die bewegungen von fahrzeugen und
truppen überwachen kann rund 700
millionen franken hat die beschaffung
der software gekostet dort das system
dass das vbs noch vor mauchs amtsantritt
bestellt hat ist kaum einsetzbar ein
großteil wird eingemottet ein kleiner
teil weitergeführt für 20 millionen
franken pro jahr die beschaffung lief
laut vbs alles andere als optimal ein
drittes problem
großflächiger sozialversicherungs
missbrauch im vbs wurden allein zwischen
2007 und 2011
25.000 dienstage missbräuchlich
abgerechnet und damit die erwerbsersatz
kasse eu beschädigt
ein fehlverhalten das unter samuel
schmid begann und für das klima den kopf
hinhalten muss
schaden 4 millionen franken und ein
reputationsverlust für die armee
[Musik]
schlachtbank für die schützenpanzer
steht bei der firma gott hat schnyder in
emmen
schweres kriegsmaterial nun noch
spielzeug
während auf dem nahen flugplatz die
luftwaffe ihre piloten trainiert und
geld ausgibt holt armas es hier aus den
panzern noch jeden fremden raus
stefan bühler ist ein profi auf dem
gebiet der beschaffung und die
entsorgung von schweren waffen zu
stehlen ein pragmatiker die haut
verständnis dafür verlegt was ich für
eine starke armee heißt dass sie mit
material ausgerüstet ist und die bilder
und videos detail ist sich auch die
flocken hat ein paar zu groß war
natürlich haben nie druck darüber was
für einen schatz muss das ist das
fahrzeug bergen
der schutz den die panzer bieten markt
begrenzt sein die hydraulische presse
kommt trotzdem an ihre grenzen wenn sie
auf einen schlag sechs tonnen metall
verkleinern muss
[Musik]
der stahl anteil der schützen transall
landet bessere stil in emmenbrücke
für stefan bühler kein schwerer gang
doch manch ein mitglied der gruppe
giardino dürften die nachfolgenden
bilder schmerzen
schwerter zu pflugscharen so steht es im
alten testament
die deutsche friedensbewegung machte
daraus in den 80er jahren ihr motto die
friedensbewegung ist inzwischen
eingeschlafen die abrüstung übernimmt
die armee gleich selbst der spardruck
fordert seinen tribut
[Musik]
eine große show um sich macht
millionen streichen der berühmte sechs
haupt seinen ausgesagt
[Musik]
vor zwei jahren befürchtete ueli maurer
die verschrottung der panzer könne das
vbs millionen kosten dem ist nicht so
die armee erzielt mit dem verkauf des
alt metalls einen ertrag im einstelligen
millionenbereich aus sicht des vbs eine
schöne stange geld
oktober
das vbs fliegt parlamentarier nach emmen
1 hier sollen sie an den blick auf den
krippen demonstrator werfen denn die
schweiz anfang mai in schweden getestet
hat
auf wald namhafte mitglieder der
sicherheitspolitischen kommission lassen
uli maurer ins leere laufen
[Musik]
sie schütten stellvertreter
verschiedene kommissionsmitglieder waren
erbost dass der bundesrat ihnen fehlende
kompetenz vorgeworfen hatte ich habe
einerseits
kommissionsmitglieder sind daniel
schreiber dünnhäutig politik disposition
da wir kraft sind so dünnhäutig wir
machen da es ist auch der bundesrat 18
ist auch
ueli maurer und testpilot fabio antonini
markieren präsenz
[Musik]
projektleiter jörg weber gibt sein
bestes
ein großteil der anwesenden signalisiert
ob so viel betreuung interesse
die stellvertreter der fachpolitiker
erfahren teilweise neues für dorffeste
politiker ist es vor allem ein vortragen
von bekannten
[Musik]
fakt ist der krippen demonstrator ist
nicht das flugzeug das die schweiz wenn
es nach uli maurer geht der einst kaufen
will
die subkommission festgehalten dass es
bei der auswahl des kampfjets heikle
punkte gab es sieht so aus als sei ein
großteil der probleme gelöst und der
rest werde demnächst gelöst ich hoffe
dass sei korrekt und wir erhalten
tatsächlich das flugzeug dass man uns
verspricht ich habe aber noch immer
meine zweifel ob
der neue jet ein papierflieger ist
darüber lässt sich streiten er ist eine
weiterentwicklung des bisherigen modells
auf persönlichen wunsch die maurer
fliegt der krippen trotz schlechten
wetters extra für die parlamentarier die
hantel stimmige geschätzt
eigentlich
[Musik]
die wahrheit dass der flügel grad doris
hat sich herr strache bezahlt anruft und
ein finnischer besonders cornelia also
dass das land ein persönliches archiv
sie wollten ja ich nehme überhaupt
persönlich dann haben wir es ernst
verständlich
dass parlamentarier wenn man einen job
patina wird deutsche die stunde sport
was ist das wichtigste wo der halle mit
gehüteten parlament
ausgeprägt
einfach durchwinken dürfte das parlament
in kfz kauf vermutlich kaum
was seither geschah
im november gab der bundesrat grünes
licht zur finanzierung des krippen über
einen spezialfonds dieser tage werden
die letzten der 330 schützenpanzer
demontiert in der innerschweiz hat die
armee sieben weitere atom schutz
unterstände ausgeräumt
für das alte munitionslager ist ein
käufer gefunden
und uli maurer wird bundespräsident die
infanterie rs ist zu ende gegangen von
650 rekruten haben rund 530 die
grundausbildung abgeschlossen
die stimmung ist und war so scheint es
mehrheitlich gut
es ist schön schick sind eine 21 rufen
ja mit also mit der coole jungs da 21
woche verbringen ich mir die qualität
gesichert
dass disziplin braucht und alles ist
eigentlich
unvorstellbar und die armee als ganzes
sie steht heute vermutlich besser da als
beim amtsantritt von uli maurer bisher
allerdings die beste armee der welt ist
dürfte es noch ein weilchen dauern trotz
motivierte junge mannschaft
die schutztruppen zeugen und herren der
rubrik
[Musik]
[Applaus]